[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we host these webinars
every Tuesday so welcome today we are
going to talk through robot games how to
use tensorflow
to build a system that can see
understand and react to the world um as
a reminder you can ask questions any
time on the platform and we've got
Google Earth standing by to answer the
questions so let's talk about how to
robot games how to build this system to
see understand and react to the real
world so to start off I'm Dave Eliot I
work in Google's cloud and I spend most
of my time working on machine learning
and artificial intelligence as do i and
I also work in cloud I'm a developer
programs engineer working with the
cloudy I teams so great let's go ahead
and jump straight in so this is what we
built this is a project that we worked
on for a few months earlier this year
and it this is what it looked like in
its final manifestation so what you're
looking at here is four arenas of what
we called AI in motion which is these
robot games and and let's take a closer
look at what these what just look like
it was the individual standing around
this this arena this is one of the
arenas you can see the the robots
evolves themselves you can see the
obstacles and people interacting having
lots of fun interacting with them and so
what we wanted to be able to do was to
take this project that Noah and I and a
few other folks worked on and make it
available for anybody to go and build
yourselves and and go and have some fun
with with your with your kids or your
significant other so let's go ahead and
take a look at what this looks like in
action itself so this is what the AI
system sees and this is how its seen
understanding and reacting in the world
this probably won't make a lot of sense
right now but hopefully by the end of
this webinar you'll be able to
understand what's happening here and
again to be able to go and do this
yourself maybe you can get some of these
robots and go have some fun at the
holiday season okay so let's talk about
what we're gonna actually right up front
what I wanted to be able to to share is
that all of these resources are in fact
available for you today so you can go to
github and look up cloud platform next
AI in motion and all the source code is
available for you I also wanted to
quickly call out the hardware is
relatively inexpensive easy to find
hardware so we used the sphero's robotic
balls the spark plus in fact and then we
used pixel and Huawei phones we actually
showed this demo in New York no no in
London San Francisco and Tokyo right and
so you can use both the pixel and the
Huawei p20 okay so here's what we're
gonna walk through today first the
design and architecture decisions we
made and then Noah's gonna walk through
the model selection and training and the
on the device deployment and then we'll
finish with QA and again you could ask
questions any time and we've got
Googlers to anybody answer no one I'll
ask her what we can yeah at the end
alright so let's go ahead jump into
design architecture so the design goals
we have four basic design goals when we
started this project the first was we
wanted to be able to leverage the cloud
and the real world so we wanted to be
able to take the cloud for and use the
cloud for the complex training intensive
and complex and but we also want to be
able to deploy this in the real world
actually on to robots themselves not
just in you know on a game on the
internet or something
the next is we want to leverage existing
tools so great things are built on the
shoulders of giants we want to be able
to leverage those tools and so we can
move quickly and get results quickly we
also wanted to leverage to use as much
automation as possible so that we can
sort of lower the cost of training which
is one of the most significant cost of
machine learning and then finally we
wanted to have fun we wanted this to be
as much fun as it was educational that's
why we created these robotic games the
key architecture decisions we made it
through the process first I mentioned
earlier cloud training so we want to be
able to use a cloud for rapid iteration
we in order to improve our models
quickly to be able to lower the cost of
using the late
cutting-edge hardware TP use and GPUs
for instance and it really only pay for
what we use second thing is the second
architectural decision we made was we
wanted to make sure that we had focus on
the models or optimization of the models
so that what that meant ultimately was
we ended with two separate models one
model to be able to see and understand
the world which which mill will walk
through in a minute
the four object detection and the second
is we wanted to have models that a model
that gave the right path for direction
for the gameplay and that ended up we
call that a commander model so today we
mentioned at the beginning that we both
are on the cloud team so why are we
focusing on on device prediction so it's
a it's a it's a good question but to me
I think it's because of the emerging use
cases right the emerging use cases that
are really interesting the disconnected
world of devices like a warehouse or and
you do an inventory management or a
manufacturing facility a plant you want
to look at defects and what's being
built or security so you've got these
these disconnected not always on devices
and you want to be able to do the
prediction in real time with these
disconnected devices so low latency
disconnected and predictions to mimic
you know the real world the hardware
decisions were pretty straightforward we
ended up looking at a bunch of really
inexpensive and fun robots we selected
the sphero's robots they're really easy
to work with a very simple set of api's
we also used the pixel two and the two
XL and I mentioned the Huawei P 20 phone
really could have been any Android
devices those either just funds that
were easily available and easy to work
with the machine learning process I
really wanted to this this is where I
think you know walk through the the
second half of this webinar if you're
not familiar with machine learning I
highly recommend using their taking a
look at AI adventures from you think Gow
the seven steps of machine learning I
summarized here the process we went
through into four steps we first
gathered and prepared the data remember
machine learning is really about using a
apples or in this in this case examples
are the data in order to make
predictions so we simulated some data
and know we'll walk through that again
choosing a model and as I mentioned
before we ended up with two bottles for
object detection and one for the
commander for making the decisions on
directions finally our third step is
really the heart of it the training the
evaluation and the tuning of the model
and then finally this on device
prediction actually being able to use
these these inexpensive easily available
disconnected devices to make predictions
okay so this is robot games and we
looked at a lot of different games that
we could have played and we settled on
these four games and they really are
sort of a snapshot of chase chaser games
the the we created these four games in
particular first was bought freeze tag
and this is we're working together
humans
compete in a game of freeze tag against
an individual AI robot the individual
robotic controlled robot would touch
each player freeze them and individual
humans would have to run around and
unfreeze each other then we switched it
around and we create a human freeze tag
where there was a individual human
trying to freeze the AI controlled
robots and the AI controlled robots
would unfreeze each other the third one
is what we called zombie apocalypse and
this was a little bit like the freeze
tag except in this case it was actually
this is one of the most popular ones
when you're tagged the human becomes a
part of the model that that chases or
pursues the other human players and then
finally we played a traditional game of
capture the flag and you scored based
upon how quickly you're able to capture
the other flag I'm running over two
designated points in the game okay so
those were their architecture decisions
we made the game design and at this
stage we could hand it over to Noah
who's gonna walk through model selection
and training alright sweet let's jump in
so as Dave was saying the first sort of
step is data gathering and prep
raishin process and so the key thing for
us is we didn't have a large data set
already of Sphero robots and with images
and labels so we needed to generate that
data set and going through we could do
it by hand taking pictures going back
manually labeling them but that would
take forever so we wanted to generate
our data set and so what we have here is
on that top image this blank canvas
image of our like arena floor and then a
cropped image on the right and so we
start placing these randomly around the
image what you see on the bottom is
these randomly placed objects and when
we randomly place up with a simple
Python script using the pillow library
we also get the coordinates of where
they are and the type that we placed so
this is our sort of our feature and
label data set and so then now that
we've generated this data set we can
generate like 1200 images and convert it
to a tensor flow record and so the idea
behind that is that tensorflow uses
these TF records to quickly access data
as well as the labels during training to
help speed up the process so we'll talk
about the conversion script a little bit
later and how we used it but after that
we upload our data up to Google Cloud
Storage so that we can store it because
this is you know twelve hundred images
large several gigabytes and so we need
to be able to access it quickly and if
we want to run multiple models at once I
want to make sure they can all access
that data at the same time so two things
I'll say that one is this goes back to
what I've mentioned before we want to
leverage automation and so these are
virtually 1,200 items that that that
Noah mentioned these are virtual items
it could have been twelve thousand
could've been a hundred twenty thousand
so we were trying to leverage automation
as much as possible and the second thing
is it might make sense for us to explain
what tensorflow is yellow is at the
heart of what we used here so tensorflow
is a machine learning framework so
there's a bunch of different frameworks
out there scikit-learn pi torch but
tensorflow
is what we used also because of
tensorflow light which will dig into
later that has a great and use for
embedded and mobile devices so that's a
sort of a library in Python as in other
languages nodejs and JavaScript but
let's jump in now so we're gonna be
talking about the two different models
we had so we have the object detection
model this is our understanding model
right at the beginning we said we can
see understand and react so our object
detection models where we do our under
standing and we're also gonna be talking
about our commander model and tandem
here about how we react to the
environment so when we first started we
kind of looked around to see leveraging
out the resources we had to sort of see
what things out there that we could use
and right from beginning tensorflow has
on their github simple Android
applications that go and provide
basically a sample app that already does
object detection with a model in there
to do keyboard recognition general
person recognition may be like water
bottle recognition very simple things
and shows you how to run tensorflow on
an android app so we grabbed that off of
their github repo and just started with
that but the problem with that was we
didn't get our custom sort of prediction
of our Sphero robots from that data set
we generated so then we had to decide
hey we need a custom sort of object
detection model and that center scare
you have millions of pictures of zeros
rope no they didn't read lis enough now
so we had to build our own model and so
that but the nice thing was we could
take tensorflow has this thing called
what they call the object detection API
and that's going to be that bottom
resource the mobile nets open source
models for efficient vision on device
and so what that is is basically there's
these pre trained models frozen at
checkpoints that do object detection
very well but what they don't have is
very specific object detection and so we
can take our data set with that model
run it through training by modifying
just some of the configuration files and
get a brand new model out that is now
trained to do object detection on our
models and the code for that is can
sound intimidating like whoa I don't
know how to do this object detection but
let's look at the next slide and just
see sort of what we have to modify and
so what we take here is we see we
modifying just a few lines in the
configuration file of the input path and
sort of the label map path and once
that's happening there is we just are
modifying that that TF record that we
uploaded to Google Cloud storage and
adding those in and then we run the
scripts that we got as part of this
model to run the training job so next
let's kind of talk about some of those
decisions we made for the commander
model that's the reacting model and so
the idea behind this model is we got the
bounding boxes that you see in the image
there we've figured out where things are
in the sort of on the MA
we've understood our sort of environment
but now let's make a decision and that's
where this model is coming in more built
from scratch to make a decision on what
the model should do and so this model is
using reinforcement and learning and
this is a technique where you're
basically playing a bunch of games over
and over and then giving it sign of a
scoring system to see how well it didn't
it's learning from that scoring system
because we don't really know what the
optimal path is in every situation when
the balls are actually out there on the
green I'm moving around and so that's
how we used the Commander model so we've
got the object detection to see the
world to understand the world these
objects and the obstacles that are out
there and then a commander models one
that actually plays a game right the one
that knows the rules of the game and
makes the determination as to what the
right path is in order for the for the
AI system yeah well not quite it doesn't
really need to know the rules of the
game it just needs to know sort of we
can teach it sort of the rules of the
game later with reinforcement learning
to play using there's no rules for game
but knows it knows what's a successful
path yes yeah we give it back that
scoring while training we're telling it
what the correct path is so now the next
part is now actually training this model
and running it and you know learning
from it and evaluating and so the key
thing to that is we can take advantage
of cloud resources using Google cloud
machine learning and Jen for training of
both models and so the idea behind this
is when we're training these models we
need a lot of compute resources and we
also have to access the data and so
that's the nice thing that Google Offers
is we have all these resources and
compute we can run many simulations at
once mini training jobs and be able to
access that data out of the tensorflow
record and so the key thing to this is
there are simple one-time setups for
this cloud training stuff and you can
follow the links to those get hubs about
about how long did it take to do this is
that simple one-time setup Oh 15 maybe
20 minutes and we'll talk in the next
slide about a resource we used that
basically tells you how to do this whole
process with a slightly more specific
model in about 30 minutes for object
detection okay great so let's look at
that so right we've got our sample
application we have that we just need to
get a model for
we're gonna train our custom object
detection model and now we just need to
sort of start that training job and so
there's actually three amazing resources
out there these three blog posts Sarah
Robinson is the author of the first and
third one dot Tran is the author of a
second that basically walked through
these exact steps with very simple
specific resources and doing object
detection as you can see on the bottom
one it's getting started in 30 minutes
so you're up and running with a mobile
application doing object detection on
your phone in 30 minutes with a cloud
training job using their cloud TP use
kind of amazing and this is another
example of using resources that exist in
the tensorflow community in a broader
community to be able to to to shorten
the time to get to actually the gameplay
itself yeah definitely so then what we
talk about is our third our second model
the commander model being run in
simulations so what you see right there
is our actual simulation happening so
our model is using simulation so that we
can run it faster run multiple training
jobs it's less expensive we don't need
to actually run multiple games in the
physical environment keep logging the
data and then go back and sort of upload
that and train from that no we can use
this simulation data to get near
real-time sort of what happens in the
real world and the idea behind this is
that the red ball is the one doing
reinforcement learning so it's sort of
objective is to try to move toward that
target point the yellow ball and which
is stationary and it's trying to move
around and get to that and then the blue
ball is what we are is our chaser sort
of just doing a simple scripted thing to
chase directly after the red ball and
the red ball is trying to learn from
that and the idea of this is it's a
target point and point to avoid
structure of initial model simulations
that we can create our chaser and runner
from this same model and the idea from
this lead from our experimentation was
led to this peak and Valley model as
much was more efficient and sort of
realistic for our runner than other
things we did and so the idea behind
this is imagine that the blue ball is
this peak of a mountain which moves and
this yellow is this pit that we can
either keep stationary or move around
and red is sort of being pulled towards
the
yellow pit and Ezer Avenue yeah gravity
sort of falling away from the blue ball
and this is sort of a common ish
technique in robot pathfinding and to
make this a little bit more realistic we
also added a aggressiveness rating and
the idea behind this was we would sort
of weight how much we wanted to fall
away from blue or sort of more push into
yellow and so this allowed us to create
sort of two behaviors when used as the
chaser you can move the target point
around to the nearest fearow robot that
you're trying to chase after and the
nearest obstacle sort of being one of
those white blocks you want to avoid and
when the runner you can kind of keep
this stationary a general area you want
to move towards with the primary
objective being to run away from the
nearest blue ball or the nearest chasing
robot and so this is really the heart of
the commander model which is really the
heart of the engine that learned to play
these games right yeah and and on top of
that this also points out again the
example of or the users of automation
that we want to be able to you know if
we had done this in the real world
be able to you know if we've done this
in the real world you need lots and lots
of examples to be able to train your
models this would have taken weeks or
months and costs thousands hundreds of
thousand dollars maybe to have all you
know the many many iterations of this of
what you've done here is essentially
simulate those games those games yeah
and one thing you might be thinking is
like okay for chasing why not just use a
search algorithm like a star optimized
and that's true you can totally do that
we started with that and our prototype
works really well but then when we
wanted to make that running away
decision you have to know where you want
to go and that's that optimal decision
we we don't exactly know the answer to
where we decided to create this model
and use it in both cases of chasing and
running which created some very
interesting behaviors we saw out on the
actual arena floor so let's kind of do a
little recap of all the different tools
we used in this training and sort of
decision making process so first up
going back to that beginning cloud
storage using Google Cloud storage to
hold our tensorflow record of 1,200
images or so and our
sort of data set and slowly increasing
throughout time as we generate more data
and then tensorflow that machine
learning framework again that we're
using because the tensor flow object
detection API has all this vast
resources that we have out there to use
as well as the tons of real light which
we'll be talking about shortly cloud
machine learning engine we use that to
run many simulation jobs speed up our
training using GPUs and TP use and the
cool thing with that is by doing that we
can speed up our training to sort of cut
down our training time from running in
about eight hours with cloud GPU down to
about an hour and a half to two hours
that we can iterate multiple times in a
day instead of just once a day that's
from GPU to TPU yes GPUs are the
tensorflow processing units these are
custom-built a sixth at are specifically
designed to run in Google's cloud to do
the types of math that's required the
matrix type of math that's required to
do the training training is the most
intensive part of a machine learning
process from at least from a compute
perspective and so having this custom
build a sixth at really increase the the
top of the speed and lower the cost of
training was really important part of
being able to do this in a quick and in
the connective way yeah and then we were
able to use the Google compute engines
to run our simulations on that commander
model by running multiple simulations at
once so we aren't just focusing all our
resources locally so next up let's kind
of talk about the on device deployment
so we have our models trains selected
and we're ready to use them we just need
to put them and into action and so
that's where we finally get to tensor
flow rate and so tensor flow light is a
solution for running machine learning
models on mobile and embedded devices
and the reason for that is tensorflow
light has this cool quantization feature
and the idea behind that is that for
these deep learning the models these
models that are very large you can
shrink the model size by removing
certain layers and you're trading off
sort of accuracy to get smaller models
that run faster and this is really
important in mobile and the reason for
that is right mobile applications are
typically maybe 30 megabytes in size and
if you add on a 30 megabyte model size
that's a bad thing it doubles your size
and I
believe there's requirements sighs on
these applications so by cutting them
down to about two megabytes you lose
maybe a percent or two of accuracy but
what you get is a significantly faster
model cutting you potentially your
inference time your prediction time what
it takes to do the object detection in
half to a smaller model and so this
enables the machine learning inference
with low latency and a small binary size
which can run on android iOS and other
operating systems and by converting to
ten servo light there's already existing
scripts to take your tensorflow model as
is and convert it to tensorflow light
and so that's again where we point out
to that blog post of training and
serving a real-time mobile object
detector in 30 minutes with cloud TP use
we'll help you run that conversion
script for you and this is another one
of those you mentioned before one of the
key reasons that we chose tensorflow not
only sensor flow wildly popular so
there's lots of resources it was I think
it was open sourced in October of 2015
and this stage it's it's a by far the
most popular open source model out there
but open so started for the libraries
out there but but also the fact that
it's it was tender for light was
designed for use cases just like this
yes yeah for mobile or an embedded
devices so now we kind of have this
diagram flowing we have our training in
the cloud those resources will be went
over and then we've converting it to
sensory flow light now we just need to
put it on the Android application and so
this we're going to be serving on device
and talking to our Spiro robots and
we're talking to the sphere robots over
there Bluetooth with their SDK and so
the idea of this model deployment is a
sort of a loop happening what happens is
the model object detection model informs
the commander model so when it goes and
does the object detection it's
understanding where things are and then
sending that information out to the
commander model the commander model is
then taking that information and making
a prediction at saying which angle
should I go what direction and the key
thing is this fear of robots SDK allows
you to input an angle of 360 degrees and
our commander making decision our
commander model is making decision in 20
angle degree increments so it's saying
cool go this way go that way and so
that's information then gets sent to our
robots and so then this loop again
we do the object detection we observe
the 20 angles just arbitrary
yeah relatively arbitrary we just wanted
to slim it down because we didn't quite
need full 360 degree support 20 degree
angles was enough of a small percentage
to get good behavior out somebody else
could do it it'd been different
incremented they need more precision
yeah sort of again part of the iterating
and sort of process of trying something
seeing how it works
once it's out on the world and then
bringing it back in and so in general
this whole loop of running object
detection and Commander model takes
about 60 to 80 milliseconds that's the
inference times less decision-making
time and that is near issue real time to
happening on the arena whereas the balls
are moving we understand where they are
as we saw in that initial video of where
they're moving around and then making a
decision based on that information so
that's the scene the understanding and
the reacting yes 80 millisecond yeah
which again is is seems like would be a
fantastic in the physical world in if
it's an online game stuff like that that
might be there might be problematic but
here it's actually seeing the direction
and the obstacles and making
determinations in 60 80 milliseconds
yeah so now we kind of see that whole
diagram coming together but then the
sort of the last piece that's missing is
sort of that multiplayer aspect that we
said where people other than Ebola
yeah the humans are coming in and
interacting and playing with these AI
robots so that's where we added this
second part using a firebase and
firebase is Google's sort of mobile
platform for cloud and the idea behind
this is we can have our devices
communicating and we use the firebase
real-time database and the idea behind
this is that that real-time database is
holding our game state and information
of who's it
who's allowed to move if you got tagged
and are frozen or if you turned into a
zombie and so we're using that real-time
database and with low latency to be able
to update that game state as things are
happening set the phone the central
phone running the object detection and
Commander model is actually also running
sort of the general game state and
sending information off to the
fire base and the other devices that the
humans walk up and we start playing with
to interact with their robots get that
update in real time and in this case we
were just using the human human players
are using phones as well yes with a
simple app on it and and they could have
been using joysticks or any other input
device and I guess it's probably make
sense to leave this up just for a minute
longer because this is really the
snapshot of the whole system right on
the on the far left side you've got the
the training in the cloud that I
mentioned before is one of the key
tenets of what we wanted to do you can
see the storage and the training using
tensorflow Google Cloud storage compute
engine TP use the conversion that
happened in the middle tensorflow
to tensorflow light and then off to the
right side serving on device with both
of our models the object detection the
scene and the commander model so really
the right model for the right job at
hand and then the the the three robots
themselves that are both being seen by
object detection and being controlled
through the commander model and then the
bottom being just the the gameplay the
the human interaction component of it
yeah exactly great so let's jump back to
that initial video and sort of walk
through it again now that we have it so
the idea behind this is right I am the
green ball moving around about to go and
chase the AI BOTS that are controlled
elsewhere and we're seeing that object
detection happen in real-time and so
I've tagged orange pink and red and blue
is still moving around and making
decision to go untag it's frozen
teammates and start running away again
and then as it loops around that top
block to go back and untag the other
teammates and the white boxes are just
obstacles oh yeah I just seem trying to
avoid a challenging factor to the game
alright so to summarize we built this
the system this year it wasn't a huge
involvement in terms of time or
resources but it was a really fun
project see understand it react to the
real world leverage existing resources
to be able to build us quickly the key
things are you're able to train a
complex model in the cloud
all the benefits of clouds and since
it's we're wearing t-shirts here but
then deploy them in the real world right
deploy them in this case I'm just sort
of fun serial robots to play these these
fun little games but again it could be
it could be a robot in a warehouse or a
manufacturing plant or security or a
whole host of other resources a whole
host of other news cases the other thing
I'll point out in summary is that all of
these tools are available today
tensorflow touch wide open source cloud
machine learning engine GCS in the cloud
are easy to use and relatively
inexpensive to use you only pay for what
you use in this case the part of it is
the training and that all of these
examples all the sample code the blog
posts are really readily available you
can go out and use them today build them
play with them over the holidays and in
modify them and build something even
better yeah and as we pointed out all of
the resources specifically the source
code and that link we put at the
beginning of the github next 18a and
motion is has all the source code links
to blog posts that go even more in-depth
as well as the other resources that we
use to build this so definitely go check
it out ok great so please stay tuned for
live QA you can still enter those
questions and we'll be back in less than
a minute to answer your questions
you
okay welcome back it looks like we've
got some questions from the live
audience let's go ahead and start with
the first one can you explain why you
use tensorflow light so going back to
what we mentioned before really - it's a
it's a question I think first why we why
we use why we wanted use in bed in bet
an embedded solution in a mobile
solution and that really goes down to
again they I think they're really unique
and interesting emerging use cases I
mean we're still really early in the
game as compute resources continue to
become less expensive as the these
mobile devices become more and more
powerful we'll be able to do more and
more of the inference more and more
prediction on these devices and I think
that's the the first question is that
there's really interesting use cases
that that tensorflow light can address
and it turns why we use tensorflow light
I think it's fair to say well I mean
Noah you made that decision yeah so I
think it goes back to the tensorflow you
can run tensorflow and tensorflow light
on android but the key difference with
tensor fly is you get that quantization
step in when you're speeding up and
shrinking your model size without losing
much accuracy and so by doing that you
have your low latency fast model without
even having to go out to the cloud so
you've got your train model on device so
you're not costing any data going out to
the cloud and you're not incurring any
network latency costs to use it usage so
that's sort of the main key thing there
is that you're keeping it locally on
device for faster things and you're not
costing your users data when they're
running it I think it's very now I would
also add to that that generally speaking
anything to do with tensorflow now is
it's becoming easier and easier because
there's such a robust ecosystem now
there's so much information out there
that that can help you be do what we've
done which is to deliver this you know
pretty quickly a second thing what's the
biggest obstacles in doing this where
did you hit the roadblocks ooh you had
hit a fair number of roadblocks well I'd
say the first biggest obstacle is sort
of with machine learning in general it
sort of being overwhelmed by either the
task and the problem or
the amount of resources out there and
trying to sift through and so I think
that's the initial sort of burden of
like oh wow this is a huge space it's
daunting at least it was for me when we
started this and but going out and
started digging through and finding
these different resources that we have
you can see oh wow they do a really good
job of explaining walking you through
the steps and so forth I think the
biggest roadblock we really hit was
actually with our commander model and
that was actually when we sort of deploy
it we have our simulations they look
great but some of the behaviors that we
would then deploy we learned oh dear
this doesn't really work in the real
world or it learns a bad behavior so if
our reward system was poor and our sort
of initial commander models the Sphero
robot sort of just learned hey if I go
move to the wall and just stay there and
don't move that's the best decision I
can make because our reward system are
you giving it back yeah we gave it a
poor reward system where you that was
its best score it could determine and so
by modifying that and moving to that
sort of target and point thing with the
sort of mountain falling away and
gravity we got a better simulation out
which then also worked really well in
the real you know and I think the an
interesting thing on this is I think
some of the biggest obstacles that that
you might hit are host of ironically the
physical part of it right the the the
mat the the walls the camera being
suspended on to the arena it's none of
it is is terribly difficult but it does
take some effort to be able to set up an
environment like that initially we used
two by fours and Lego bricks right yeah
just hold our camera camera in place and
ultimately what you saw in the images
earlier were things that were put
together by a you know an interactive
professional agency a hardened so they
can you know go around the trade shows
but that was actually an interesting you
know the physical development and it was
one of the passion challenges but the
videos were done with our just prototype
two by fours we went to Home Depot
bought some plywood put it together done
50 bucks or less you know
of equipment all right can you apply
this to other common scenarios aside
from gaming yes game means fun but as I
mentioned a few times to me the you know
one of the really most evidence they use
cases is in a warehouse in inventory
management right you could set up simple
cameras to be able to look at a
warehouse be able to track things as
they move around to be able to see
what's happening in that warehouse then
to be able to understand that oh we're
short on this we've got overabundance of
that and then to make decisions based
upon what it sees to be able to take
corrective action and then ultimately
through maybe warehouse robotics to be
able to take that action to go in and
automatically order resupply have it
delivered and resupply those shelves
that's a simple real-world example on
top of that you can also do some defect
detection so if you have an assembly
line sort of going by and you're
checking your products for defects you
can go and monitor that as well with
this sort of same technology we've done
in something else with a similar thing
using the same resources that we had for
object detection to create something to
detect if there was a error in say one
of the objects moving by and say hey
this is like a good object this is a bad
one and then you could use a second
model to sort of make a decision to
react to that and either pull that bad
object aside or make an alert and have
one of your staff come up and grab it
move it and do some manual inspection
from there so there's a lot of things
you can do it's just sort of coming up
with the idea of what to use this object
detection for well and it's really you
know but I talk a lot about machine
learning and it's really gotten to the
stage where you need to think of the
world as sort of you have systems now
that can can understand the world right
whether it's understanding somebody
speak or understanding somebody what's
happening in a in a video or in physical
pictures it could see the world and
understand what's happening in the world
and that's once you realize that you can
take that and put it on disconnected
mobile devices I think that the the
litany of things you can do really
becomes interesting and give a really
early
this this is just an easy way of showing
how how this this can be done I did want
to touch on the last question which is
can you review the github repositories
so this will this should be in the
bottom of what you're looking at on your
screen I think we included just about
all of the links including the Google
cloud platform AI next yeah
the repository that's the main one that
will at least start getting you out to
the other ones that we used right so so
hopefully we've answered all these
questions most of your questions if we
didn't we've got people who are directly
answering them online so at this stage
we're gonna go ahead and wrap up stay
tuned for the next session building chat
bots with dialogue flow and I've been
looking forward to this because this
we're out in Mountain View but this one
is live from New York with Whitney
Building chat BOTS with dialogue flow
thanks for joining us